well speaking of pocahontas and these
tedious racial politics
disney plus is banning classic movies
from young audiences audiences under
seven
namely the people who watch disney
movies
which movies dumbo peter pan swiss
family robinson and the aristocats
no longer available for young users
on the disney plus streaming service
why you ask well because of political
incorrectness
because of racism here's why your kid
can't watch peter pan right now in
disney plus
the film portrays native people in a
stereotypical
manner that reflects neither the
diversity of native peoples
nor their authentic cultural traditions
it shows them speaking in an
unintelligible language
and repeatedly refers to them as
redskins an offensive term
according to white liberals but not not
really deemed defensive by
indians themselves peter and the lost
boys engage in dancing wearing
headdresses and other exaggerated tropes
a form of mockery and appropriation of
native people's culture
and imagery all of that's gobbledygook
and it's completely meaningless
culture requires appropriation if you
want to become cultured
you need to appropriate different
aspects of culture
you need to behave in certain ways you
need to
speak in certain ways you need to
develop and cultivate
cultivate from the same word as culture
certain
tastes
i'll i'll try to be as i always tell you
i try to be
as unprovocative as i possibly can i'm
italian
i am well aware of italian stereotypes
we like eating lasagna we talk with our
hands as you can see i'm doing right now
we have certain uh
stereotypes that go along with that
culture right
if i strip away all of those stereotypes
i take away all the lasagna all the
pizza all the bippity boppity boo all
the speaking with your hands all that
kind of stuff
all of the physical characteristics
because i don't want to be racist or
culturally appropriative
i have just erased the culture
i have ironically done the thing that
the
left pretends they don't want to do
right because the left castigates
conservatives when we appropriate
culture but they also castigate
conservatives when we don't
appropriate culture when we erase
culture it's a it's a damned if you do
damned if you do scenario but we give
into this because we're so afraid of
being called racist or whatever
don't do it racism is bad because it's
an offense to human dignity that's why
we shouldn't do it
good done put that in a box tuck it away
you're good don't worry about it anymore
don't worry what these
cynics and idiots and nefarious
political actors
think about you if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
[Music]
you